[Music]
chase is with us in los angeles hi chase
how are you
hi i'm grateful to be alive how are you
guys same here brother what's up
um so i've been listening to you for
about a year now um and i listen to you
every day on my way to work i
pretty much dream and fantasize about
getting debt free and i'm having a hard
time diving full into your
program into the baby steps uh i'm a
recovering addict i'm a recovering
addict i've been
sober two and a half years good for you
and i just have this
thank you
i just have this giant fear of losing
everything and i have
you know like when i when i was on drugs
i you know was looking for change on the
streets had no money calling people for
money all hours of the night
and um now that i have you know a pretty
good savings at 15 000 in my savings i'm
i'm really terrified to let it go that
you know i'll lose everything like i did
in my addiction
um
and i'm just kind of wondering what
advice you can give me to make that leap
of faith and just
go all in
for you so what were you addicted to
meth
whoa good for you that's a tough one to
break yeah proud of you how old are you
it was really hard
i'm 33
wow and what's your income now
um well i uh sell cars used cars and
this year i'm on track to make 90 000 a
year good for you man that's amazing
you're amazing guys thank you
thanks previous to that i was making uh
20 000 a year as a flight attendant okay
yeah um so this this big jump in income
um it's been pretty great for me um how
much data
i have 58 000 in student loan debt i
just cash flowed my last semester
and
i have twenty one thousand dollars in a
car
i have
three thousand dollars in collections
and i have uh twelve hundred dollars on
credit cards okay
and that's it all right
well i'm very proud of you
uh
breaking an addiction is a tough thing
breaking meth is a really super tough
thing
uh you're
i appreciate that and um and now you're
trying to address other behavior things
so here's the deal
when you were uh walking down the street
looking for quarters because you're a
meth addict
uh that's a different guy than i'm
talking to isn't it
it is okay yeah i mean but your body as
dr john deloney says your body remembers
the terror of being broke
yeah combined with the drug addiction
yeah it terrifies me yeah i know i have
a good head on my shoulders now um but
what i'm my point is is the the thing
that is welling up inside of you
then you physically feel it probably
is the you when you think about being
without that 15 000 it takes you back
you just told me this so i know it does
it takes you back to picking up quarters
on the street
yeah however you and i both know that
intellectually that is not the reality
the reason you were on the street
picking up quarters was meth it wasn't
15 grand
yeah if you'd had 15 grand you'd have
spent it on drugs
yeah and you're not that guy now
exactly yeah so our intellect tells us
that the facts are
is operating in a completely different
mindset in a completely different world
than the terrifying thing that's keeping
him to move forward on this
does that make any sense
yeah it does i just needed to hear it i
guess yeah so you are more worthy than
than your guts tell you when you start
talking about pulling the 15 grand so
i'm gonna do something i almost never do
here okay
uh-huh
i'm gonna modify
my advice a tiny bit
okay okay because i'm empathizing with
the way your heart rate is going up when
you're talking about this normally i
just call people a wuss and tell them to
bone up and do it right okay in your
case i'm going to do the same thing but
i'm going to give you 30 days
all right here's what we're going to do
today
i want you to pay off the credit card
and cut it up that's 1200
and the collections that's three
thousand dollars
okay now we really didn't affect your
cushion very much mathematically agreed
yes you're still sitting after you
finish that on twelve thousand and some
change agreed
yeah so you're still okay breathe
but what that little experiment does is
i want you to get the high
oh that's a bad use of words i want you
to get the joy
i want you to get the joy of having paid
off the debt
right okay okay and then you're gonna
compare that to the fear
from your past
all right and then i'm gonna tell you in
the next 30 days take the rest of that
money down to a thousand get your butt
on a budget and tear into this thing
like i would everybody else okay
okay but today and then one week from
the day i want you to sit down and write
out somewhere how it felt to pay off
those two debts because let me tell you
what you're going to feel i'll go ahead
and tell you
you're going to have a sense of power
empowerment yeah you're going to have a
sense of i'm in control
because part of being an addict is
you're out of control and you need a
sense of control to move forward into
your new self don't you
yes
yeah
and chase you you mentioned the sense of
security with the 15 000 but it's an
illusion because on the other side
you've got 84 000 in debt
and so there's not a place of safety
until you're completely out of that debt
and you work at a used car lot could you
sell the car and get a car off that lot
for nothing and drive that around while
you pay off the rest of this debt would
that give you another win
um i've i've thought about it i
i got an appraisal a couple days ago
they offered me 19 on my car i owe 22 i
think
if i cancel like the warranty and gap
insurance that i bought i could get it
close to 19.
yeah um and then i could possibly buy a
wholesale car from our wholesale lot we
get wholesale prices i've thought about
that now we're getting creative
and do that and do that with cash now
we're down to just a student loan
yeah you can use some of your savings to
even do that and get out from under this
car yeah go buy you a five seven
thousand dollar wholesale car
which is a ten or fifteen thousand
dollar car or whatever it's not probably
ten thousand dollar car right buy it for
seven yeah and uh use some of that money
for that
now we're out of card debt now we're
just down to a student loan
and making 90k and making 90k this thing
out man
hey i smell success i smell it in the
air brother yeah
you got me excited there we go so here's
what you but and i think you're gonna be
more excited when you actually wake up
and those two deaths are gone you can
draw put them on the refrigerator draw a
big red line through collections a big
red line through the credit card oh you
got to cut up the credit card that's
part of the exercise okay
yeah i've uh cut up two of them yeah oh
you're not there yet this is all in
brother three credit cards this is all
in put it up right what i hang up that's
all in okay that's right
yeah and i'll tell you what we want to
be part of the final steps of your
healing you have done such a wonderful
job in the journey that you're on you're
such an important guy right now
we want to put you through financial
peace university so we're going to walk
with you while you do the rest of these
things
but
what you're going to experience there is
what people experience in the early days
of doing their debt snowball when you
pay off that little one you go yeah then
you pay off another one you're like yeah
and there's an emotional thing that
happens even though the math is small
because it's an action associated with
taking control of your destiny
and i can't wait for you to come do your
debt-free scream that's gonna be a
powerful one yeah
that'll be fun
and you can we'll pull this call up and
play part of it
and um you know a year two years from
now and
five years from now you're a baby steps
millionaire and man you'll have a
testimony what a story yeah story man
you're amazing it could inspire a lot of
people way to go dude if you can beat
meth you can beat debt i mean that's
that's my line of the day oh that's a
billboard right this guy's impressive
way to go chase